ثمانيه علامات جائعه توحي بالعنف وسوء
المعامله
شريكك يتتبع كل ما تفعلينه مراقبه مكانك
ومع من انت في جميع الاوقات
منعك او تثبيت عزيمتك عن رؤيه الاصدقاء او
العائله او الذهاب الى العمل او المدرسه
[موسيقى]
التحكم بوسائل التواصل الخاصه بك اسرار
شريكك على الرد فورا على رسائل البريد
الالكتروني والمكالمات والمطالبه بمعرفتك
كلمه المرور لمواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
والبريد الالكتروني والحسابات الاخرى
[موسيقى]
تصرفات الشريك المسيئه بسبب الغيره بما في
ذلك الاتهام المستمر بالخيانه والتحكم في
كيفيه انفاق المال واستخدام الادويه او
وسائل منع الحمل بالاضافه الى اتخاذ
قرارات يوميا نيابه عنك مثل ما ترتدينه او
تاكلينه
الاهانه في المعامله العمل على احباطك من
خلال اهانه مظهرك او ذكائك او اهتماماتك
ومحاوله اذلالك امام الاخرين اضافه الى
تدمير ممتلكاتك او الاشياء التي تهتمين
بها
الغضب والمزاجيه قد يتصرف الشريك المسيء
بغضب او يكون لديه مزاج سريع او لا يمكن
التنبؤ به لذلك لا تعرفين ابدا ما الذي قد
يسبب المشكله
العنف الجسدي
الاذى الجسدي مثل الضرب او الدفع او اللكم
او الصفع او الركل او العض استخدام السلاح
او التهديد به
العنف الجنسي بما في ذلك الاغتصاب او غيره
من الانشطه الجنسيه القسريه
التعرض للتهديد قد يهددك الشريك المسيء
بتسليمه الى السلطات بسبب نشاط غير قانوني
الى ابلغتي عن الاساءه او اذا قومتي